i wanted to do an up kind of album
and the song physical
i
i loved
but wasn't really sure if it was i was
going to record it in the beginning i
was very ambiguous about whether i
should or shouldn't do it and then
it kept coming back to me and haunting
me and i thought i have to do this song
it's really a great song
[Music]
and it just kind of happened that way
there was no preconceived nino i think
people imagine these moguls sitting
around and putting together images but
it really just kind of happened
[Music]
i mean i don't think
um personally
i came out of xanadu too badly i think
the film
liked
a story basically a script
[Music]
but the music did very well and that was
really the side that i was the most
concerned about um in the long run
because if the music had felt that would
have been devastating to me but the
album did so well that it kind of made
up for it as far as i was concerned in
the beginning i think i used to get
terribly affected by by criticism
because then you're very insecure
anyway
but now i suppose i've reached
a level in my career where it's not
going to make or break me so it's not
not as devastating as it was then well
greece got terrible reviews and was one
of the biggest films ever made oh my
gosh she is the biggest icon that
australia's ever had other than the
kangaroo
she's she's it
if you mention her name i mean olivia
newton-john she's she's everything
there's so much more interest lately in
your home country of australia it seems
to be all of a sudden but it's been
growing over the last few years and it's
going to stay that way i think we've got
a lot of talent out there i've just been
waiting for you all to realize it
there's a lot of similarities between
australia and america and but i think
australia was kind of like america
probably was
before
the population growth is as it is now in
australia i can honestly say without
sounding big time that i cannot go
anywhere without people saying hello or
how's chloe i'm i'm their family i'm
part of the family because i've been
kind of in every newspaper and the
population is so small they can't help
but see me
so there they they expect the girl next
door i guess
and
everywhere i go people treat me like one
of the family which is wonderful
you're a comedian huh
no american
well really she's a mannequin that's
brought to life i think the thing that
she doesn't know about is our feelings
and that is something that she comes to
learn about um when she joins the family
[Laughter]
[Music]
i was a little nervous about if i could
pull it off so i said i'd like to do a
screen test please and see if i like it
because i want to know if i can do it so
i did a screen test with john and it
really worked and we had great chemistry
and i felt very comfortable
sandy
tell me about it
i think that the the last scene you know
when we were filming that it was such a
change for me because i'd been two
months as sandy one as i call her and
then i got to change and be sandy too
[Music]
and i spent time in the trailer with the
makeup and the hair and the wardrobe
we're trying different looks and
different you know what went with what
and what earrings and stuff so i went
out on the set um and nobody knew who i
was and i was getting all these
looks and whistles and i think what have
i been doing wrong all these months
and it was really uh
very fun it was really fun that i could
pull it off and
you know it was great
the doctors were checking me and i had
you know i had lumps but none of them
were
anything to worry about and i had
mammograms but this time it felt it
didn't feel quite right and i didn't
feel well within myself and i had kind
of a knowing that i didn't feel
quite right and i always say to women
trust that instinct because that
instinct in women is very powerful i had
a mammogram and it was negative but i i
went to see my surgeon and he didn't
need a biopsy which was also negative
and i still didn't feel right and he he
said to me i think i'd like to do a
surgical biopsy and that's when they
found it because it was hidden right
away so
my instinct and his wanting to really
check it out were very fortunate for me
i'm a pretty positive person generally
although breast cancer is a scary thing
to go through
but i made a decision pretty early on
that i was not going to give into it and
that i was going to be okay and you need
to decide you're going to be okay and i
felt that
in in my deepest core and in my soul i
knew that i would get through it but
it's still a very scary thing and you
don't really know you just have to go
through it that's the only way you learn
how do you spend a perfect day perfect
day uh i had one today really i got up
early
i fed my dog and cat
had a cup of tea get brought one to my
husband had a really nice morning i mean
today was a busy day but just to be at
home with my animals my husband
maybe had chloe there for visiting um
just hanging out
[Music]
sometimes hearts can grow as cold as
stone
this is something that you recorded
during the pandemic correct it is it was
a really um
interesting thing that happened because
i had not planned on recording again
[Music]
the first person i thought of was chloe
um to sing it with me because it was
such a personal song
and luckily she agreed because it's not
really her genre of music but um
it was a very special thing to do it
with her i was honored that
you know out of all the people my mom
could have asked she asked me so
that meant the world to me
[Music]
in this particular time in the world i
think was the perfect message
to have compassion for each other and
friendship for each other this is a very
unusual time on the planet and we are
all
so connected and we need to value that
connectedness not our divisiveness and
um just to share in the love because
we're all here at this time together on
the planet and we are all one
[Applause]
of all your songs do you have a favorite
people ask me that and there's so i like
a lot of them you know because obviously
i mean i have to really love them to
sing them in the first place but if you
really had to pin me down to one of them
i'd say that honestly lovey was one i
love you
[Music]
when you were a little girl in australia
growing up did you always want to be a
singer did you know that this that
hollywood was the place where you would
end up one day no never i'd never any
idea
um i wanted to be a vet actually and um
because i was animal crazy still am
haven't changed much but um i wasn't
very good at science at school or math
so i kind of passed on that one and
singing just kind of
happened for me i used to do it for fun
and somebody heard me singing in a
coffee land tries to sing with a folk
singer in there on the weekends and
i went into a talent contest and won it
and it kind of
you know spiraled from there
[Music]
you